[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
ein weiteres cupcake rezept im moment
bin ich ja total verrückt nach leckeren
cupcakes und deshalb dürfen bounty kokos
cupcakes auf keinen fall fehlen
[Musik]
ganz wie beim bounty regel bestehen
meine cupcakes auch aus kokos und
vollmilchschokolade ich zeige euch jetzt
erstmal die zubereitung die schoko
muffins habe ich euch ja schon in einem
separaten video gezeigt das verlinkte
ich euch auch noch mal in die infobox
für das frosting benötigen wir
schlagsahne mascarpone ein wenig
frischkäse
außerdem gibt zu kt kondensmilch und
sahne stand mittel nun geben wir
mascarpone frischkäse und sahen in
unsere rührschüssel
[Musik]
die gezuckerte kondensmilch geben wir an
der stelle auch schon mit hinzu und die
haben einen total leckeren
eigengeschmack und wenn ihr die
verwendet dann braucht ihr auch kein
extra süßungsmittel mehr
nun hört ihr das ganze kurz durch auf
niedriger stufe und sobald sich alles
einigermaßen miteinander verbunden hat
also schon nach wenigen sekunden gebt
ihr dass seine stand mittel mit hinzu
und schlag des komplett steif auf der
höchsten stufe
[Musik]
das frosting funktioniert auch nur wenn
die zutaten komplett gekühlt sind also
direkt aus dem kühlschrank kommen
[Musik]
sobald alles schön standfest ist ist
euer frosting auch schon fertig und es
kann losgehen ans dekorieren und dafür
teilen wir uns das frosting in zwei
spritzbeutel auf einmal habe ich vorne
dran eine schöne raschen ball piping
tipp die macht richtig schöne muster
ihr könnt aber auch jeder andere
verwenden und auf der anderen seite habe
ich gar keine tolle denn da scheint sich
einfach nur die spitze ab und es reicht
schon vollkommen aus
desweiteren benötigen wir geschmolzene
voll mit kuvertüre und hier habe ich
vorne nur eine ganz kleine spitze
abgeschnitten
nun wird zuallererst auf den schoko mal
finden eine runde haube gespritzt da
könnt ihr mehr oder weniger nehmen
ganzen möchtet und das muss auch nicht
ganz so schön sein denn man sieht vom
muster sowieso nichts mehr
denn an der stelle danken wir das ganze
in reichlich kokosraspeln das ganze
sieht so ja schon richtig richtig gut
aus und ich find's richtig süß mit der
kleinen haube aber wir machen einen
richtig schönen hohen eleganten bounty
muffin bzw cupcake und deshalb spitzen
wir jetzt noch eine richtig schöne große
haube darüber
[Musik]
für die deko geben wir dann noch klein
geschnittenem mini bauen thies auf die
haube und dekorieren das ganze dann noch
mit leckeren kokos chips und unserer
voll mit kuvertüre
[Musik]
mir persönlich macht das dekorieren von
cupcakes immer total viel spaß was seid
ihr für typen liebt es auch cupcakes zu
dekorieren oder seid ihr eher sony
becker die das ganze lieber zu bereiten
und das dekorieren jemand anderen lassen
schreibt mir gerne mal in die kommentare
das wird mich total interessieren
[Musik]
im kühlschrank halten sich die cupcakes
übrigens bis zu drei tage dafür solltet
ihr sie allerdings luftdicht verpacken
also einfach den deckel reporten glocke
darüber geben und dann kann da auch
nichts passieren
ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen de leckeren bounty
cupcakes die genauen mengenangaben die
findet ihr wie immer unten in der
infobox
[Musik]
ich danke euch herzlich für das
einschalten und freue mich wenn ihr
meinen kanal kostenlos abonniert damit
ihr beim nächsten mal auch nichts
verpasst und dann sage ich bis zum
nächsten mal auf griechisch kitchen
[Musik]